you've had so many different jobs and
career paths and one of them was
you were like a
male dancer
were you like a stripper what the [ __ ]
is going on i
like to party
jesus this is unwaxed get in loser we're
going shopping with sophia and sistine
salam did we just become best friends
[Music]
slip slide trying to provide for me
i'm gonna leave that into the intro
hello you guys and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters
sistine and sophia
well
it is a what day is it today wednesday i
keep thinking it's friday every single
day this week i thought it was friday
it's better it's a busy weekend so i
feel like when you're anticipating a lot
of plans for the weekend i am just fast
forward your week because i've planned
everything fun on a friday so i'm
counting down the days i need to shower
and wash my hair using like my malibu
crystal if you guys know what that is
when you have you know what actually
let's break it down before we get into
that
sophia and i have such an intensive
self-care routine before a big night out
that it's actually a little bit
embarrassing ruins our week but i really
think we should share it yeah i mean i
can say mine then you can say yours if
you want
okay so sunday night i went to a full
body scrub where this lady flipped me
over like a piece of meat and scrubbed
me raw until my skin was off but let me
give a pov imagine you're sitting
on
oh
what are those tables called like when
you're dead and they're like oh i was
just a morgue you're literally okay so
imagine you're sitting on this
embalming embalming yes yes so imagine
you're sitting on one of those tables
yeah it really isn't
bright it's as bright as this room is
right now there's no dimming lights no
and there's a giant shower above you and
they just turn it on and you're lying
there like a dead face and the music is
all kind of opera and old-timey music so
you do really feel like you're probably
transported back into the 40s and then
this woman comes in
and she just goes to town every cracking
crevice of your body she's seen more
than any other person more than my mom
anything so she gets you that
rub down until like that sounds really
weird for 75 minutes and then you leave
it you're like okay i feel fresh i feel
like i've just
was reborn yeah she puts you in a
pretzel position and yeah my foot could
go behind my left ear so this entire
week also we're working out we're eating
super healthy then i go okay i have my
hair cut and styling on friday so
washing my hair i need to do it every
other day so i won't make my hair too
greasy so i make sure like today i'm
going to wash my hair fully shave
everything because tomorrow on thursday
i'm going to be putting self-tanner on
self-tanner is the most key step because
you have to time it out correctly yeah
you can't shave the same day you can't
shave the same day if you two too soon
it's gonna be blotchy by your weekend
plan if you do it too late you're gonna
smell like b.o
so tonight
fully shaving got my scrub gonna have my
hair done on friday the malibu crystal
treatment is to get all the minerals out
of my hair because l.a water it's
horrible you see in a relationship
though my my self-care routine has
completely changed and now i kind of
have to adjust to when i'm gonna see him
because
i can't put tanner on when he's over
because then you smell like i'll get it
all over him it's a mess i mean that's
that's the tricky part
actually speaking of the washing hair
thing i saw this girl on tik tok and a
lot of people say that you're not
supposed to wash your hair you're only
supposed to shampoo like once a week or
something like that and she was going on
tick tock like day
17 without washing my hair and i was
like first of all you are definitely not
in a relationship or working there's no
way there's no way that you're i'm so
sorry someone with 17 year old dirty
hair
if i work out i need to wash my hair or
something i can't be in bed with
literally grease in my hair let's not
forget you got your nails done oh yeah
nail's done that was last week i'm
trying to think what else i'm trying to
do that was literally yesterday no way
before a meeting
wow that was also this week wow um yeah
so and then yeah friday full glam we're
already tanned your hair is going to be
done yeah makeup done outfits are chosen
and this is all
for one night literally for one night
for once just freaking night on friday
insane
people and i hope we're not alone out
there i think there are other women that
yeah we're getting some for like dates
maybe i feel like sometimes i i'll do
like a mini version of this before a
date i'm really excited about but i
think overall like normally i don't tan
like my entire body it would just be the
things that are showing you know i've
said that like my face or my legs and
even more eating will change because you
want to
look real look and feel your best
because when you eat well
it kind of your skin looks better you're
glowing you look snatched do you do this
for face times with people that you
haven't like let's say you're facing a
guy you like do you make yourself look a
little bit better you have better
lighting or you have like maybe a cuter
offer i'll tell you this
a facetime call is so strategic for me
but it has to be so fun like the balance
between looking like you just
literally answered the phone and woke up
like this to looking really cute and
presentable and like maybe a little bit
sexy is so hard it is i got called out
if you don't think that i'm like testing
the light 10 minutes before you call me
then i got called out for that because
my lighting was too perfect that's
embarrassing um yeah how do you think i
feel and he said he literally said the
lighting is too perfect was that set up
i'm like no my lamp is just like there
and he's like no it's set up here's what
i like to do
put on a tank top
you know a nice push-up bra doesn't hurt
but then you got to put on a flannel you
know what i mean so you can finagle with
it you can shift it around yeah yeah so
it looks like you know you're just like
lounging at a house but you got a cute
tank top on
you know make sure your lashes are
people it's just it's ridiculous we're
like you're putting way too much effort
you're honestly at this point the guy
doesn't know who you are really who you
are because the entire time you're just
something that you've been working on
for over two weeks well that's what my
biggest fear is
well you know it used to be my videos
so it's different it's so different but
with
my previous relationships i was so
self-conscious to being not literally
naked but like naked with myself yeah do
not even like no makeup not hair done
yeah aggie sweatpants i didn't want him
to see the real me because i thought he
wouldn't be attracted to it we had this
conversation last night or i was having
this problem with you last night
that i was feeling like i couldn't be
vulnerable and be actually myself
because every time i was i felt super
insecure about things well i think
insecurity comes from different places
because for me
i've never noticed i was insecure about
something until someone made it a point
to tell me
and then i became insecure about that
thing yeah like i never thought i had a
big chin until i got compared to the
crimson chin all the time or one time i
was dating this guy and i was washing my
face before bed and he said ah now i see
the real you and i was like
oh my god yeah and at that point i was
like i can never not
have a little bit of concealer on
because i don't want them to think i'm
unattractive
but
when
in your instance you're saying that like
your insecurity comes from your own head
yeah everything is in my own head i
think that some people can relate to you
where their
their like flaws were like identified by
someone else but for me if you're like
me i'm a perfectionist
i don't like messing up or feeling like
i messed up because i don't want to
have them perceive me a certain way or
if i say a certain thing they're not
going to like me and unfortunately that
kind of
is just one it puts way too much
pressure on myself and i feel like then
i can actually be myself in the
relationship because i'm not being the
thing i think they want me to be and
then two
how are they actually gonna like me like
if i'm not being who i am right off the
bat that's what i wanted to tell you if
my mom always told me this that
whenever sophie and i were insecure
about something or venting or this
person's not gonna like me because of x
y and z
she always says [ __ ] them if they don't
like you for who you are and all your
corks and your flaws then why do you
want to be with someone like that anyway
and not to uh make you a little bit more
insecure
but i'm pretty sure you're wearing your
sweatshirt backwards right
now oh i am yeah
i am you're so right so how did you
notice oh
does it do you see the label oh yeah you
do see the label yeah this has been a
fun morning for me
yeah i know but you're so right and i
was hard on myself and i was giving i
was getting mad at sisting because i was
trying to make her see it from my side
and she thinks she kind of saw a little
bit of like why i was feeling this way
but i completely agree like i need to
work on this i am very chatty when i get
nervous and i will say everything and i
need to let the other person talk
sometimes but i also need to stop being
so hard on myself and say okay if i
say this certain thing like i'm very
open about everything like i if you want
to ask me anything about
dating sex my anxiety whatever i will
tell you a whole novel about it and
instead of feeling like that's a bad
thing to be honest and open about it why
don't i go okay if you can't handle that
and you want someone that's a bit more
serious then don't go out with me
there's there's a fine line to teeter
because you don't want to show all of
your cards and reveal everything and
more to this person and that's the thing
like i used to have a bad habit of
literally exposing every single version
of myself and every single quirk
on the first few dates and then there
was nothing left to discover and it kind
of just got dry so i do think you know
keeping some cards close to your chest
is important i think it's a little too
late i have like two cards left in my
deck and well hold on to them
you know what see that's why this
podcast is so great we just saved a
100 therapy session yeah really though i
know we really did and i actually wasn't
planning on talking about this at all
but if you can relate
be you
don't feel to yourself and the right
person will come be you all right i want
to talk about who we have coming on the
show today i am
stoked yeah and before he comes in the
room you guys
i have to vent because i'd be too
embarrassed to say this to his face but
he has a podcast called stiff socks if
you haven't already seen it it's top 50
in all comedy podcasts
i am an avid stiff sock listener she is
i am i think i listen to every single
episode i am so excited that he is
coming on the show today he's a comedian
a writer an actor
i mean his stand-up career is blowing up
he's on tour constantly so we have
michael blaustein joining us so stay
tuned
you have the incredible comedian actor
podcast host of stiff socks podcast
michael blaustein stereo audience here
it is here it is i can't actually
believe that we tied you down for this
episode
sophie and i when we were writing our
guest list you were like at the top
honestly no seriously because you're so
busy you're touring you're going all
over the place i mean your comedy career
is taking off it's wild yeah it's it's
absolutely wide i'm like insanely
grateful but it's like it's i haven't
had a second and be like this is cool
it's just like a constant like right get
on a plane
yell about feet to hundreds of people
get off a plane do it all again yeah do
you sort of feel like it's you're just
like a machine now like it's so routine
yes i mean it's like it's again it is
you take a step back you're like dude
this is so sick but at the same time it
is i mean dude i came in here yelling
about how tired i am it's it's just it's
a constant
dude and i said before like literally my
girl knows my schedule better than me i
don't know where i'm going yeah so
people like where are you going to go
tomorrow i'm like dude i don't have no
idea don't know do you hate the airport
now it's the worst it yes you truly see
the worst people ever and i was saying
to him i was like people are 10 times
hotter at the airport than they actually
are in life but then i also think
they're wearing a mask
no before i used to think everyone was
kind of hot in a weird way because they
wear a hat and like hoodies and stuff
like that am i going crazy no no you're
not going crazy i i do think that
especially in lax
they're people dress up yeah to go to
the airport yeah here's my theory though
i think coming out of la or coming out
of miami coming out of new york i think
a lot of women or dudes get flown out so
when they land you're getting picked up
by the dude or woman that flew you out
so you got to look back that's why
they're wearing heels
[Applause]
my thing is whenever i go to the airport
and i lock eyes with someone that i
think is remotely my age i'm like are we
having
sparks like other why is it when you see
someone at the airport that's similar to
your type you're like wait are we having
a connection yeah let me ask you this
though
when you see someone that's hot to you
have you ever sat next to them i
honestly thought i met the man of my
dreams turned out it was a
huge mistake she went on a date
yeah we did and he was dressed into the
nines i remember i looked homeless i
looked so bad that day so per usual per
usual but i was looking extra ugly on
this fly she was wearing the ugliest
hoodie i've ever seen in my entire life
but why was it so ugly okay so i i woke
up feeling like i'm scared of my
reflection so i found a hoodie that was
so big that it went all the way down
into my lip so literally my half of my
face you look like you were like
bohemian growth like you look like that
okay like darth vader like you can't see
anything on my face yes and all i'm
looking at is his uh uh his feet and so
i'm like wow those are nice shoes and
then i go up a little bit i'm like nice
pants always wearing a cardigan he's
wearing a
a scarf we didn't like scarves
originally but the little class we liked
cardigans
he gave me the vibe of like a
specification he was coming from new
york i was like this this guy's got some
swag going on he comes no he doesn't
he's wearing a car
by the way that was a red flag i thought
so many red flags i was delusional at 6
a.m okay but i honestly was like this is
the guy in my dreams and i choked so bad
because
he looked at my backpack and he's like
oh i really like your backpack and i
don't know why i got nervous i was like
thanks i can literally fit my whole
closet in it
what like
that's not bad that's not bad i thought
i thought you'd be like oh i have tampon
like i thought you said something
way worse yeah yeah way worse i feel
like all closets
like oh god but anyway yeah we did go on
a date and it turns out we love psycho
with anyone at the airport here's like
this weird thing that always happens to
me i always ask people if it happens to
them
i'm [ __ ] you not when i was single i
would literally like look
at someone in the vicinity of the the
gate that i'm at yeah yeah i'm like damn
she's hot she's reading [ __ ] catching
the ride whatever she's just like you
know just a little bit of you know i'm
like ooh substance right um i don't know
why catching right but you guys get it
so we um a book yeah a book just a book
yeah um so i was like oh wow and then i
[ __ ] you not
i was batting like 70 percent that she
would sit next to me
on the airplane did she do no no i'm
saying 70 in terms of like this probably
happened to me
five to six times stop and they all i
[ __ ] you not dude and i would i would
get on first
and then i would see them kind of
getting on and i'm going
i bet you they're going to sit next to
me and without a doubt either next to me
or in you know or in a row i have a
theory we were just talking about this
off-camera energy
energy but i also crystals crystals
manifestation you put it on your vision
board secret the super secret the super
secrets
someone should write it again and be
like the sequel secret is called the
super
secret guys
just talking about off camera that we
think that we have a theory that
restaurants seat people based on
attractiveness so maybe airports do the
same thing and if they see two people
that could potentially be a match
of her instagram we're like this is this
is a good match dude let me tell you
something if they are worrying about
that i'm gonna be pissed because why
don't you worry about getting pilots to
fly my [ __ ] it's true that's never
happening it's like it's crazy i never
get that i always end up getting the
person i least likely want to sit next
to it i see the person across the way
i'm like is this man sexy i know he has
a nice back so he's probably in like
probably that same area i'm in and all
of a sudden he said text me and doesn't
stop talking i get the talkers and i kid
you not it's when i have my headphones
in my hat my hoodie yeah that they're
still going hey oh they touched oh they
do well that's a that's that's a problem
you gotta say
yeah i know the last time this guy was
showing me how he is a pilot and i was
like oh that's cool nice and he was
showing me all of his takeoffs and
landings for 30 minutes on this flight
uh-uh yeah
can so tell me what would you do if
you're in that situation here's here's
the issue that i see and please push
back if i'm wrong i think you're too
nice
that's true even if i have nothing
playing yeah i will i always make people
repeat it because i'm like how much do
you believe in what you just said to me
because i actually said because if you
go hey and i go and i have my i go i'm
what just not not a like not like a what
just like in between like probably
doesn't like what's up oh what's up
that's your actor coming in you guys i
said yeah
he literally kept going
and i go yes and he goes well i just
said and he wouldn't stop oh the yes
that was pretty good
sorry good no and then he just kept
going and so i gave up and i'm like okay
i guess i'm just going to watch a plane
on a plane almost 40 minutes on the top
of the airplane
i don't know because when i go to the
airport i actually never look good i
don't think i've ever looked good in the
airport unless i'm going on media 20
what are you doing filming it's audio
i know it really breaks the entire thing
no but i i feel like some people try to
cotter i just get meaner and i don't
know why i don't know if it's because i
impatient i don't like waiting in line
when they go through my luggage when i
have nothing in there it's always me
they're like checking all the perfumes
that i have or something it stops
carrying so many large ounces i love
perfume just go
below 3.5 and you're good you're trying
to do a whole thing oh i love it i have
to have my options
because i have a different vibe for
every guy girl person i talk to so you
just spread and you go you are this is
my no no let me tell you sophia
is like who's sophia i'm joking go ahead
watch my take offs go ahead go ahead
i say sophia's like the man from split
she has so many different like personas
so she will literally
put a different scent on for the
different kind of vibe that she's
wanting to have on a date she'll kiss
differently
based off of the date like what i'm
wearing is she what she's wearing so
no literally she's changing she's like a
chameleon i need to go into this are you
going like personality chameleon yeah
let me explain this because assistant
thought this was super weird and i've
said this and no one knew that i
intentionally did this so depending on
what the date is and who the guy is i'm
like okay if i want to go in looking
like a little sex kitten so i'm going to
wear a little crop top little tighter
pants heels
do my makeup a little bit more risky i'm
probably going to have a makeout that's
a little bit more forward forward and a
little bit more aggressive and then i
wear probably perfume that's more musk
if i want to be sweet musk what does
that mean like like um like i love how i
asked you what musk is and you said
musky
sick dude
absolutely
[Applause]
like a billiards event and she just has
billiards
okay okay okay
okay
i don't know if i'm wearing a dress
that's a little bit more floral so we
all have a more rose
that makes sense maybe i will kiss you
maybe i won't because we're just but how
do you differentiate is it like
restricted
i just decide on how i want him to
perceive me so you don't know who you're
dating
at all
okay do you think do you think your like
personality changes in that realm or is
it just like a yeah this is a slowly i
honestly think well you need to fix that
i think she does the opposite if it's a
bad boy she'll dress like more
innocently and do the rose thing but if
it's a good boy she'll try to be like
sexy dominatrix yeah but how do you make
that call though you can kind of tell
when you look at someone i don't think
yes i think that some people are very
outward in terms of like who they are as
people i think most people aren't though
no honestly a lot more people are secret
dorks than i realized that would thank
you i'm like oh you're a player but then
often they end up liking bionicles or
something
hilarious
jesus reads about lincoln this guy loves
lincoln i love oh yeah lincoln yeah i
always hit the lincoln logs
no oh i love a good link what was the
last time you guys did legos i want to
get back to this but i just yeah
honestly so long ago and i was saying to
sustain i made a joke about how guys
usually get girls flowers on random days
of the week i said what do you get guy
on the random day of the week legos like
would they like that yes i feel like
they would
i feel like they would use it too is
there another thing besides flowers i
think flowers are so like just so hacked
no my dad calls flowers a bowl of salad
he's like who wants that that's she
gonna give him a hundred dollars dad
should probably write movies it is he
should yeah yeah yeah he was adjusted to
him but yeah i know i think the date
thing kind of doesn't work because in
the end i end up being who i am and they
don't end up like well no they like it
but they just that was so sad you just
said she's been very self-deprecating
lately
oh you just meet him like on rye or some
[ __ ] you meet him like at a bigger event
because i love my belly i don't know why
i said billiards it's totally fun i it
made so much sense to me
yeah with the billiards table is that is
billiards pool right actually okay so
make sure that's right so how do we go
from village to pool real quick i don't
know
a pool you dive in a pool why is a pool
also billiards i don't like i don't like
it yeah i mean guys i don't do cheating
all the time i feel like you do i really
don't i don't
she also pre-orders her meals before she
i don't order no i don't pre-order you
don't think she's looking at the menu
before the restaurant and then getting
the menu when she sits down like hmm
what looks good like she doesn't already
know she's getting the grill family too
much
i'm really in my head
very much so how often do you how often
you go on dates not that often sophia
once a week at least once a week at
least once a week no like a new dude
uh sophia
don't know
it depends uh well i it's because you
say yes it depends if i say yes she's
passed out a lot hold on hold on hold on
let's take let's say
you you said you so more than once a
week no once a week max once every other
week too [ __ ] you can't say i go out i
go on a date every single with a new
person with a new person no no no
usually it ends up being like three days
i'll tell you this most guests that
leave this couch end up asking her out
after the interview uh oh yeah uh oh
well what musk are you wearing are you
wearing like a actually she's the one
that wears more of a muskie scent i wear
vanilla yes see that's the problem i
know dude vanilla bruh man i don't know
what it is it's vanilla what it but i
don't i don't understand i know do you
guys love it is that their sense look at
me yes i do not know what it is i need
to buy it i don't know
i have a i can't believe you don't know
i know i tried to beat that both of you
are single
[Laughter]
[Music]
listen up ladies going to the pharmacy
is so 2021
you can get your birth control online
prescribed and delivered free with the
pill club gain time and peace at mind
with the pill club their licensed
medical team puts your reproductive
health first with access to affordable
birth control period care and sexual
wellness products with all an online
subscription look life is stressful
enough luckily getting birth control and
sexual wellness products can be one less
thing you have to worry about with pill
club you'll never have to make that
horrible trip to the doctor or when
those lines at the pharmacy ever again
pill club delivers your birth control to
your door and free discreet packaging
along with self-care gifts and goodies
if you need to renew your birth control
prescription want to switch your birth
control or maybe try for the first time
the pill club medical team has your back
get help finding the best option whether
it's a brand you know or not with the
pill club it carries over 120 fda
approved brands and ships to all 50
states most brands of brick control are
free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance oh
my god
want more
i bet you do their licensed medical team
is just a text away to give you the best
reproductive health care advice right
now when you go to the pillclub.com
unwax the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org for every
unwaxed listener who becomes a patient
your donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's
thepilclub.com
unwax to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember the pill club.com
unwaxed you must use the link to make a
donation
[Music]
our next
partner of the podcast is the iconic
athletic greens it is a product that
sophia and i actually started using
because we wanted more energy well
mostly because athletic greens doesn't
taste like it's super healthy it kind of
has more of like a mild tropical taste
that you can look forward to when you're
using it in the morning so you're
probably asking sophia
what is this stuff yeah with one
delicious scoop of athletic greens
you're absorbing 75 high quality in
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right so what
does the special blend do well it
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
focus recovery aging it goes on and on
also athletic greens is lifestyle
friendly so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free so if
you read the
the nutritional value and all that stuff
like i do it contains one gram of sugar
no gmos no nasty chemicals or artificial
anything while still tasting good it
supports better sleep which we all need
and recovery and also supports mental
clarity and alertness multivitamins are
so important just for anyone to take
tons of people take some kind of
multivitamin and it's important to
choose one with high quality ingredients
that your body will actually absorb like
athletic greens athletic greens is a
great company and it's super focused on
sustainability they are a climate
neutral certified company in 2020 they
purchased carbon credits that support
projects protecting old growth
rainforest additionally for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious foods to kids
in need including no kid hungry here in
the u.s in 2020 athletic greens donated
over 1.2 million meals to kids you guys
right now is time to reclaim your health
and your immune system with the
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into flu and cold season just
one scoop every single day and that is
it there's no need for all those pills
and supplements to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
unwaxed again that is athleticgreens.com
unwax and take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance yay
[Music]
when we first met you okay and that was
in florida and you were with trevor we
met through trevor you had to stand up
and you were also there but i feel like
we kind of knew each other-ish i think
it's like ish social media issues yeah
yeah
so when we walked in
we literally looked at each other we go
stop it we know it's that guy he's that
guy oh yes i want you to know yeah that
you taught three generations of
stallone's how to make out
dude you guys are really welcome i'm
literally trying to write a bit about
this and i can't i just kid you not you
taught me how to make out and now
i've been told i'm a great kisser i'm
telling you you're welcome dude so wait
i really want to break this down ask me
whatever you want anytime you want to
see you look the exact same thing yeah
you don't age one year thank you you
don't need your benjamin
to give the listener some context
there's a how cast video
starring this gentleman
of literally how to make out
and it gives in-depth detail of what to
do and like
you don't talk the entire time we
you're like mute so
how the hell did you get yourself in
that scenario all right so obviously my
career was going great i want to see how
many views this has dude
over a million over a million dude
there's like 50 of them and they all
have over 20 like milk it's nuts i
remember when i was growing up i i
didn't have older sisters that tell me
anything so of course i'm a researcher
so i go okay i'll be going she said on
the internet and youtube and like look
up and that was the first video and i
got okay like
what i i know don't i mean how many i'm
telling you there are whoa yeah there
are 2.8 million views and that's just
one video you look like a there's
passionate kissing
it's like a baby no it looks the same
[Music]
yeah wait so does she just ask you can
you do a makeup video it's just 12
million
it's all wow my comedy was going well so
i literally had to call them and tell
them to take my tag off all of them
because when you would look me up yeah
oh i'd like to get tickets to the sky
show you'd look me up and did 400 videos
of that no no one's going to a comedy
show if they're watching that by the way
that made us want to stay for your
entire side
we were fangirling so hard
i feel like that's like my youth it was
no offense like you were my child
we're like acting like you're 80 years
old
i had to get like a lawyer involved like
it was like it wasn't crazy because
they're actually being nice but like
they weren't being so forthcoming up top
and i had to like work them through it
but it was a it was a business issue
like again like i feel it yes i feel
like the nostalgia of like oh cool
like because i he like listened or
taught me how to kiss i'll go to a show
blah blah blah but it's like that's not
what you want
you want people to look at a bit and be
like oh sick he's funny let me go back
did you know when you were doing that
video that you were going to be a comic
i was it was pitched to me like it was i
was going to be like the comic relief of
this
and so i was going to come in and
the whole like idea of me actually
kissing was never
put forward and then this is my story no
like what am i just sorry for crying
yeah um but yeah the idea of like
kissing was never it was never like
positioned to me it was always like this
youtube person is going to like talk
about kissing and you're going to like
a weird liner yeah exactly and
most of what i quote unquote did for
comic relief wasn't put in there and it
was just very much like just straight to
the point just straight to the point
yeah and then like everything that kept
was like you know whatever she's like
how do you
what is your and i would like give my
take like a serious take yeah so it
looked like like it was you got
bamboozled i did i did i got bamboozled
and i left the i left the studio being
like
whatever bro it's not gonna be seen like
it doesn't matter
it does not matter well i made it with a
stranger for like 12 hours like this
doesn't matter it doesn't matter at all
have you ever seen her since
i
yeah
you guys pen pals once after and then we
like sorta kept in touch-ish
and then
yeah and then i think like i don't know
how long after but it went nuts and
there was like there was like an ish
like reality show pitch that we're gonna
do whatever i'm so happy that nothing
else that nothing went through it's kind
of crazy now you realize like how many
people can't kiss
oh oh yeah
oh it's a problem yeah oh it's a it's a
big big issue i was thinking about that
like i cannot believe that video has 12
million views yeah because people don't
know how to do the proper i mean i was
how like 12 maybe when i was watching i
think i was in high school
but that's the generation it's like oh
yeah i don't know how to do something i
don't know how to change a light bulb
what do i do on youtube but i don't know
how to blah blah so that's i mean yeah i
don't know if that's like the first
compilation of its kind but like maybe i
haven't seen anything like this though
anywhere else well i think the sao on
that is so crazy that yeah there
probably is but it's just buried it
makes total sense does it haunt you
today thank god is not like i kind of
like just like leaned into it a little
bit and because every so often i get
that's the guy from the how casting did
people come up to you and recognize you
from that mm-hmm
do you think
god it's it's way more like comedy
related hey you're the guy from what or
whatever so thank god but
but yeah i mean it was
i think when it started kind of going a
little viral like
um i was like still like doing shows
like colleges and stuff yeah and that
was like a little bizarre right people
would be like hey
but
again there are definitely comments on
my tick tock whatever if i post a video
but hey that's the guy from whatever
whatever but it it's it's
like very much died down oh good thank
you thank god i'm talking a bit about it
i just need to sit down and work on it
but like i've tried to i bro brought the
idea a few times on stage and the
response
because i think there are a lot of
people they just already know or are
trying to figure it out yes so if i say
it's what and i was like yeah videos
bubble kissing and like not the whole
audience but a lot of people are like
let's talk about like they yeah that's
why you have a girlfriend now because
she saw the video and she was like who's
that guy exactly exactly
yeah yeah there's nothing to do so
to pivot about your stand-up comedy
career when sophie and i saw you on
stage i couldn't even believe the amount
of energy that you can exude yeah like
you are yelling you're fun you're
calling people out i mean i was getting
hyped up just walking really good
with people that are like good you have
this like natural ability just to even
doing a podcast you just know how to
naturally riff off of people have you
always been that way um
i think so i think i was always sort of
like the
the class clown sort of like oh i don't
know who'll do it oh michael do it type
of person okay and uh yeah i mean dude
even at like a really early age like i i
remember like making i remember
literally the moment i made like my mom
laugh when she was like mad at me like
when i remember i was like six i
remember this so distinctly and she was
like kind of being mad at me and i don't
remember exactly what i said but i said
something i defused the entire moment
and she started dying and then she just
like forgot about why i was in trouble
and then i was like oh
i'm gifted
this is a cool skill that i had perfect
and even like in school like
getting like grades and and stuff and i
i think i was like raised i was like
raised by women and so like as a dude
and being raised by women you sort of
like you understand dudes because you
are one yeah yeah and you understand
women i mean obviously everyone's so
complex but on like if i'm painting with
a broad brush i feel like i do
understand it more things yeah i get it
more
that's a better way to put it yeah i get
it more so even like with that skill and
then also like comedy like in high
school dude i would like get grades that
i for sure didn't deserve like my french
teacher would give me grades that i
failed everything and they should be
like man you you gotta be and like would
just give me i love that so it's just
like that like the really good
communication with them and like the
understanding yeah yeah and just like
humor just started getting me
just like getting me things and i was
like oh this is like pretty sick did
humor get you girls in high school yeah
yeah yeah i bet it did i feel like every
girl looks for the funny person yeah and
also like again with like to being
raised by women it's like so many of my
dudes friends are being like too
like too aggressive or not like not just
[ __ ] listening and yeah
just just literally just that piece of
it that's all women want dude
just to listen and like i
just knew
just innately all of that stuff so like
oh my god friends like asking me for
advice and blah blah blah and so like
but yes answer your question like the
getting the girls thing is like being
like a little bit funny and then like
just listening and just triple threat
he's tall he's funny and he looks tall
screw tall five nine take the compliment
no but that's the problem after like an
hour and ten minutes on stage and i have
a bunch of stuff about i wish i was
bigger but all this kind of [ __ ] they
still will come up to me like take a
picture with me like uh dude you're way
taller on stage every
[ __ ] time well you're like yeah i'm
on an elevated platform five feet higher
but even like booker's like i'll walk
into a comedy club and they're like your
poster looks like you're taller i'm like
dude oh my goodness is that a
requirement yeah i don't know what about
my headshot makes me i don't know i
think my shoulders and i feel like if
you just look at this piece you're like
oh okay yeah you broad shoulder do you
think the shorter you are the funnier
you get yes dude i swear to god if i was
if i was like six two i'd be the most
unfunny person in total because you
don't have to try it
why is it that the taller you are you
just think that you don't have to do
anything because they don't because you
don't because there are so many people
dude it's just like
kind of i used to be the girl that would
go after guys because i thought they
were tall sophia wouldn't date below six
three well that was because i had a
short my ex was six seven well that's
just too tall so now my head
then when i started going out and dating
i thought everyone was short but he was
just incredibly tall because my my
mindset was used to that wait how tall
is your girlfriend five
three oh she's small she has to be she
has the tea but she's actually you like
petite girls
i do like people because i'm small like
i'm small i also i'm like i like to be
way more dominant like a bed so i can't
i've tried it yeah like you know in in
new york it was a girl that was like
five nine and i was like it's okay yeah
yeah and it's just not for me it doesn't
that's fair like i can't i can't care
throw her on the bed like that buddy yes
she gotta have it it's not a big deal
for guys like if you can't pick up your
girl and throw on the bed for me it is
okay because i but there's definitely
dudes who like
can kind of be a sub and a dominant but
like to for me to be a sub is so
violently disgusting oh you can't do
that no dude it's so i just
no no it just doesn't work but what if
she's like michael like please like let
me
tie you up tie you up and like put a bag
on for a whole hour no no no you can't
no no
no because here's the thing like and i
feel like everyone has the ability to do
this but like i can if i walk myself
through something i will walk myself
through something like i will i will
like um i'll feel like how like i will
smell the room i'll feel how like the
chains feel like i'll walk myself
through it not to again not like this
i'll be very specific on how i feel okay
so i can make a choice if i give myself
a moment and i so i'm not like making
this choice kind of it's like it's like
kind of blank choice i've walked myself
to it it's gross to me the choking the
spitting all that kind of stuff like
that's so hot to me and yeah the inverse
yeah no no no no no it's not she's not
she's just not different strokes for
different folks and bro i'm into so much
[ __ ] so like yeah i'm really yeah has
she always been very open too does it
just work like that it it it very it
works really well because she's very
much like that person who's like and
very open but like in the streets dude
she's like works for tech and she's like
you know she like does big business bro
so she's like how did she snatch that i
don't know he's funny
honestly for real he's funny no it was
it was love though
i never saw a successful dating story so
congratulations you're my first one raya
yeah i always think that it never works
out dude i was on raya for two weeks
yeah yeah i was i was doing the whole
like bumble bee what was your first
message well hooked her in
dude i don't even
know
i don't know i i think a lot of people
like what what do you say i think people
forget the
the baby yeah the baby how are you right
what the hell happened you know what
true hey how are you
when guys do the mo sometimes they'll
send us the dog emoji and then under it
they'll be like sorry my dog ran into
your dms but while i'm here what's up
i'm like oh god kill me
kill me most and i feel like people
think today we need to be so intricate
about the messages we said we don't
honestly i'll notice a message saying
hey how are you that's it yeah because
hey how are you cool not a psycho
hopefully you click on the profile okay
he's six seven i meant
you know
six seven perfect you cannot say
anything actually
so circling back to
your openness and your openness about
talking about like your kinks and your
likes or whatever
so you are very vulnerable on your
podcast and while you're doing stand up
about what you like does your girlfriend
ever get like annoyed with you that
you're kind of sharing details or it is
a learning curve i think we are learning
how to
figure out how to be
me but understand that i'm representing
the team
and it's a
we are we are learning day by day to try
to figure out not even like the line but
just how to figure out how i can be 100
like my authentic self but also
understand that i am i i still need to
have i still need to handle the moment
to moment in a respectful way right
towards her and let me tell you fine
balancing it's a very fine balance and i
have done well in a lot of places i
[ __ ] up in places and then we had
those conversations and she's like
emotionally mature she's open and so we
can sit down and have dialogues and
we're in the we're in the process of
figuring out because it's also just like
how long has it been eight months oh
muscle time
no no i was in a relationship i think
the longest one was like three and three
and a half years what happened
uh
sophia no no but ask me a lot i do i i'd
much rather what happened yeah tell me
[ __ ] tell me
whips are you heartbroken
yeah
um
i mean so the three the three year one
was i met her and i was like this girl
is so [ __ ] cool and we connected so
much
um
but the chemistry
was off and i was we were pushing that
away like the sexual chemistry we were
pushing that away because the
compatibility was so strong right
and so we had so much fun and we were
laughing and we'd like to see oh my god
yeah so
that lasted i mean broke three years it
lasted three years and eventually we
were just like i mean dude we were not
i'm a hyper sexual person and we were
just we were just and she is too but we
i just was like i don't want to i don't
think people realize that that's such an
important part when you're dating
especially in our age like yeah people
don't prioritize the sexual chemistry
they just think that like an emotional
one is enough but it's really not or
vice versa yes or vice versa yeah or
vice versa it's all sex and you're like
yeah this person like who is this person
actually then you said dinner like oh my
god we have nothing to talk so she was
more of like a friend she was not even
like a like a best friend sister type
thing because once we got through that
initial kind of like bubble the sex was
really good right but it was just weird
like i just don't want to
interesting yeah and so it was just a
call she felt the same way
um or was it more one-sided it was a
little bit more one-sided yeah
and she was also like let's have a
person that wouldn't advance yeah she
would say she always wanted to but i
would have to advance and i never wanted
to uh so with mike with my girlfriend
after that and my girlfriend currently
both of them were very much like
let's [ __ ] go oh and i'm willing it's
willing and like open and like doing
you know even just like
just simple just making advances yeah
and i didn't realize how [ __ ]
important that was to me and like i
advanced too but having the girl advance
as well is
is really nice for a dude like it's
really nice you don't have to always be
like hey baby
it's nice for a girl to like want to
take your chances you know that when you
met your current girlfriend that she was
probably going to be your girlfriend yes
yeah i knew i knew there was uh i knew
there was like opportunity yeah you know
you sit down with someone you're like oh
dude absolutely not right but i dude she
was like super smart from a good family
like oh wow um yeah so initially i was
like oh she's super cool we got along
she's like successful successful so i
was like are sick and then yeah dude the
first time we like hooked up i was like
oh thank god oh yeah honestly think
about like because i mean isn't there
that thing like post that clarity that
after you have sex with someone you you
really either you want to lie with them
or you want them that but also like the
act itself right cause like i don't i
have this i don't want to teach
i hate to have to like
hold someone's hand through and i've
tried it i just don't like it yeah yeah
i'm sure
i'm over it right so but with her it's
like she we we have great we have great
sex and she's super open in that regard
too and i think the coolest part about
her is she is you know that whole like
lady in the streets freaking yeah she's
she's dead bro she sounds awesome dude
she's sick man you guys would love her
she's super yeah i want to be friends
with her so people talk sex and tech and
yeah
she's fixing tech oh dude new podcast
she's gotta host it though so i wanna
talk about your podcast stiff socks
which is top 50 in all comedy podcasts
yes what the hell
incredible thank you
yeah it's having uh the show in the last
like four or five months is having like
a moment like it's doing it's doing
stupid well i'll tell you this i'm a
subscriber you're an avid listener ah i
honestly love your show because i listen
to a lot of female podcasts but i feel
like when i listen to you and trevor's
talk it's like i'm dissecting into a
male's brain yeah and i love hearing the
different opinions and just boy talk
because it's kind of like
mindless no offense but it's like fun
you guys just riff and it's so much fun
and you tell hysterical stories and
there's one i listened to recently and i
was like i must ask you about it yeah
you're basically like a cat with nine
lives i feel like you've had so many
different jobs and career paths and one
of them was
you were like a
male dancer
were you like a stripper or something so
what happened funny dude you're a sales
dancer so this is so funny so exotic
dancer already put it shortly yes wow
but like think of like uh what's that
show uh uh chip and nails right yeah so
think of that but like packaged in more
of like a broadway show thing like i
can't picture it so i'm watching like
hamilton
no no not that like channing tatum 100
not not that sophisticated but it's like
it wasn't so much
um it was definitely like chip and
dale's esque right it was definitely
like oh oh number number number and all
the girls like take your [ __ ] shirt
off like and you do yeah yeah
oh yeah but there was yeah it is so
funny it says but that there was a
narrative like there was yeah you know
so it wasn't
what was the plot dude i don't [ __ ]
know
it was it it essentially it was just a
mask narrative to get into the next
number so the bachelorettes could see
you without a shirt on like literally
like that was it but it wasn't as
aggressive
as like a chipmundels how do you get
that confidence to do that that was
literally like my first thing that i
booked in new york and my buddy oh yeah
i was working at a restaurant were you
on broadway no it was off probably but
like my buddy
my buddy was working at a restaurant
with me and he like pitched me the idea
he's like i'm doing this thing i think
you'd be good at it whatever whatever
and he's like still one of my best
friends ever and uh and and yeah i mean
there there's obviously like comedy
elements to it but
yeah i mean so i i dude my literally in
my audition was oh my god
oh my god
audition i went to see their practice
okay their rehearsal whatever
and the book or i'm sorry the producer
came up to me and he was like so i heard
that you're interested in being part of
the cast i was like yeah i'd love to
like it looks really fun i have a bunch
of like i had like three friends already
in it um and he's like cool google so
like this is kind of weird but i'm going
to ask you to like
i need to see without a shirt on and i
was like oh dude yeah no problem so
too much off he goes
gosh yeah and so he's just like let me
see you know pants next wait yeah yeah
dude that's what that was going to go
did your dad also go to one of your
shows yes dude my dad what so
this is well first of all my dad and i
have a very unique relationship like
he's a very like he's obviously my daddy
loves me in sports whatever but we have
a very a crazy open relationship i think
that's awesome yeah and i think he's
helped me because he was dude he was so
open to me when i was young young like
i'm talking about like 10 11 young he
was like telling me like wild [ __ ] and
so
so i think like that aided in my ability
to like not be embarrassed to like talk
about anything yeah but with all that
being said he came to that show and he
didn't know what the [ __ ] it was he's
all like proud of his son that he like
son had an off-broadway show exactly in
new york
yeah in new york and uh he brought my
stepmom was there
bro and oh my were they front row he i
don't i don't remember where they were
but it's like that you know that whole
like shirt off and that whole [ __ ]
you know grinding on black tourette's
and all kinds of dogs he's like this
isn't cats yeah
whoa
yeah these are the jersey boys yeah yeah
yeah where's the singing
there actually was something
he was singing
there was there was a dude
no no no no there are
three or four members that are actually
currently on broadway like like broadway
there's two that are in aladdin and one
that's i can't remember the show
oh dog they're like people on that show
were hyper talented oh wow it's one of
those things where like you're like dude
i'd rather do this than work at a
restaurant yeah yeah
money and then you just keep auditioning
for other things yeah so there's a lot
of people who are like really really
talented magic mike yes like honestly
you guys were kind of the first magic
mics yeah yeah honestly
awesome yeah very much so yeah yeah oh
my gosh so funny it was just such a
funny thing after the show was over and
my dad and my stepmom were there their
like reaction to it was like that
um
[ __ ] yeah dude like if great like
they were they didn't know how to react
you have to make a bit about that that's
so funny i know that from the makeout
king to becoming don't miss
dancer tonight how do you write a bit
like honestly it's it's an experience
that sometimes i just get emotionally
charged over
um and i sometimes i'll just like write
like jot down a note on my phone
and i do a lot of my writing when i'm
like walking like i'll just take a walk
around my neighborhood walk my dog yeah
and the act of walking for some reason
it kind of like
it kind of mirrors a little bit of being
on stage like the movement and so that's
kind of how i write i'll like walk and
kind of like i'll have headphones in but
no music and then i'll just like talk
like i'll just talk a bit and i'm like
oh that's funny and i'll sit down and
i'll write that piece like sit on the
curb write it get up and and then keep
going that's
when you're on stage when you're not
doing well and you're maybe bombing and
people are not reacting like how do you
keep it going why don't bob i'm so
[ __ ] talented you know yeah
he's like i just take my shirt off
start grinding it's actually funny you
should just take your shirt off any time
all of a sudden let me tell you
something ladies i've look there's
hilarious there were
early times in my career where you start
standing up you're just not funny you're
just not funny it takes five years to
get remotely funny right right oh wow so
there are times where you're just
bombing and there was a time there's two
times where i took my shirt off and it
was wait you really did yeah dude
because like one i was like i just was
stupid man i like didn't understand how
like the ecosystem of comedy worked so i
would so i'll go on stage with like the
crate the tightest v-neck in the world
and i'm like guys how come no one's
paying attention it's like what am i
[ __ ] doing so there's a lot of times
like not a lot of time that literally
happened twice where like some like i'm
not doing well whatever and then and
then like i'll take a pause and it's
just some dude like whatever dude take
your shirt off like
so and there was one time where i was
like oh yeah and he's like yeah and i
took my shirt off and then as soon as i
did it i'm like
now what you idiot yeah in my head
so and you're bombing yeah and now i'm
just making it worse so there was yeah
you're literally naked
emotionally yeah and physically yeah and
just bombing oh my see that like when
someone would heckle me i would
literally be like you shut up and start
crying because i get nervous you're
you're good at the comebacks without
clarity well dude now i love you now i
love it hold on if you guys come on my
show don't do it but like i do love if
i'm like doing crowd work or or
someone's like for some reason like kind
of talk in the corner like kind of on
their phone or even somebody yells out
something i actually like it because one
it's like it's just a it's a unique
moment in the show right and there's so
much comedy yeah in people yelling
something what do comedians truly feel
uh when there is a heckler do you guys
just absolutely hate them there are
certain people that absolutely hate them
and there's some people that like it it
for me personally it really depends on
where i'm at in my set and if i'm
working on something new or i'm like
actually trying to get something to
accomplish like again like working on
something new if someone yells out some
[ __ ] i [ __ ] hate it cause i'm like
dude i'm just trying to do this if i'm
like riffing and talking like i usually
do a bunch of crowd work up top so if
i'm doing that and somebody else or
something cool let's talk let's whatever
but when i get into when i like switch
gears i'm in like your material mode
yeah and if i'm like working on
something new if someone yells out
something i'm gonna [ __ ] pissed
because then it's like dude i don't
we're done we're done right right
now it's you shut up you sh you can be
silent i don't care yeah but like let me
do this i think they also forgot that
this is your job of course like this is
your career yeah it's like i wouldn't go
to someone's office place and start
playing like the tambourine be like wake
up like it's like i feel like you can
also get the opposite because i'm
assuming you probably have groupies yes
that are now wearing sandals front row
at your stage because your bit about
your love for feet is so hysterical
like you're just such a foot make-out
king yeah
so do girls actually wear like open-toed
shoes now for you i guess crazy my dm's
being like oh i'm gonna get my pedicure
what what color should i yeah dude
and in the front row literally put feet
up like just in in joking way but here's
the thing that i've
run into now and it's it sounds
i i don't mean to sound like i'm not
grateful for all this because i really
am but there is there is downsides all
this when people are excited to see you
it's like
you can be too excited yeah and it's a
weird it is weird to have to kick
someone out of a show that's like
wearing your merch and it's it's this
weird thing where i'm like guys i'm so
happy that you're excited but now you're
ruining the show dude i was in san
francisco and you guys know that the
floor monitors on the stage
so i literally this dude this couple
like would not
shut up and in a very excited like i
would say you know whatever a punch on
about sanitize crunch and they'd be like
cinnamon toast like they would just like
shut up they're just excited right yeah
but they're ruining momentum they're
ruining for the people the vibes
the timing of it yeah yeah i mean it's
it's [ __ ] music man so if you like if
you're getting in there it's it it ruins
it a little bit yeah so i literally had
to sit on the floor monitor like and it
was a big stage so i'm like sitting the
eye to eye like i had to like get like a
father i was like guys
gave him like a [ __ ] full talking
like you're being selfish all these
people paid all this while you're on
stage oh why am i missing performance
performance and i'm i go for like a
minute and a half like explaining how
like selfish they're being does everyone
else here do you have the mic to your
mouth
everyone's oh my god it's like being in
the principal's office very principal
office right and the problem with doing
that and why i don't do that a lot is
because i'm super silly on stage so it's
so if i break the facade of silliness
and then i'm like blah blah blah getting
very serious and then i got to go back
to silly me it's a weird transition dude
no it's weird because you have i mean we
even say this like with our podcast like
obviously we we talk about things we
over dramatize things so you make it
more of a i mean our show is called on
wax like we're trying to make comedy
yeah and that's the same for you it's
like i don't think people remember like
you're also a person they also have
other sides where i'm like actually much
more introverted or i like to have
serious conversations especially when
you're on stage and memorizing an act
and you're performing for people oh my
god it's like you're what's the
difference between singing a song and
someone's like you suck yeah you're like
oh [ __ ] dude there's so much more
respect and to your earlier point you
were like you know like a broadway show
or when people are playing music nobody
talks no nobody yells out [ __ ] yeah it's
wild and for some odd reason comedy they
feel i don't know if it's a sense of
entitlement or they feel like the
ecosystem of a comedy club they're like
they've seen it on tv or they just feel
as though they're allowed to do it i
think it's more maybe they feel like
you're saying things that they can
relate to yeah so you guys are at a
comfortable friendship we're having a
conversation a conversation yeah so
i told you that's probably the broadway
show is like you know i'm like opera i'm
like i can't relate to that you want me
to start to harmonize though
yeah dude
100 yeah so it definitely feels and
that's that's the point right the point
is like we're all having a conversation
we're all like becoming like one crowd
or one person across so it's like that's
the point but i think you're right like
it's like they feel as though we're
having a conversation so now i can talk
right oh my gosh i could ask you
questions about comedy forever but i
will wrap up the show let's do it some
rapid-fire questions do it i'm ready
okay
are you gonna start oh yeah go crazy
what secret conspiracy would you like to
start
joe
rogan is in fact elon musk oh
they are the same person
yeah all right if you think about it
you've never seen him in the same room
before didn't they do an interview yes
they didn't have all right but they were
the same person and that's how editing
works you guys want to know you're right
body double cgi exactly cgi you guys
weren't there if you could fight one
celebrity in the ring who would it be
can you give me a little more details
are we talking about like is there like
money involved or am i just fighting
okay there's a million dollar fight but
it's more purely like i'd like to punch
this first oh good yeah word word okay
this is good um
oh man i don't really hate anybody but
like who has like a very punchable face
yeah we love punchable faces here's a
weird one yeah and if he wants to fight
me i'll definitely fight him uh bryce
hall and i think a lot of people feel
this way
i don't know why
i'm sure he's fine yeah but for some
reason you're like i just want to hit
you i want to fight yeah i just feel
like he's a [ __ ] nerd
he's a very insecure nerd and he's like
and i'm like get i'll kill you
i will kill you yeah yeah i will also
dance at the same time yes
let's go
okay if you cloned yourself
do you think you guys would be friends
wow your face just went blind yes yeah
yes i think i think
if i was in like performative mode i
think it would be
hard for two people in that same mode to
be friends if he's sitting right here
and you're talking to him do you think
you could be friends yes i do like
casual friends yeah i really do yeah
that's good actually if you said no
think about that if you couldn't be
friends with yourself yeah that's pretty
sad well that's uh you know i think we
all hate ourselves on some level but you
know oh my god i hate myself you hate
yourself
[Laughter]
i really would interesting question
sofia how many chickens would it take to
kill an elephant
whoa
a full-grown elephant yeah full one how
many chickens full grown chickens they
can be steroided up too but they're
peaking they're knocking yeah they're no
they're like extraordinary they're like
kind of buffed oh jack yeah
yeah they could be jacksonville yeah
they could be jack chickens i think i
think chickens now reject like yeah yeah
they're actually like they're good
you see the chickens with pecs yeah okay
these chickens are pecks so chicken's
all female right because roosters are
the dudes and chickens is that real
that's real oh my god
jack jacks
yeah women chickens and there's a vagina
a giant elephant i'm gonna go with i
think
i think um
also chickens are vicious if you're
persistent i think uh i think about
three hundred chickens could [ __ ]
outfit yeah yeah you're gonna say 50. i
was like
they'll go into the trunk yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think chickens would would eat an
elephant up and then make a piano out of
it oh yeah god that actually would be
scary okay so worst name to have um
orville redenbacher i'm sorry that's
horrible that's a horrible name orville
redenbacher in 2022 orville hello
welcome to starbucks what's the name on
the order orville redden marvel orville
horrible orville redenbacher oral vole
orville where did you come up with i
have no idea it's oral run boxes of
popcorn and i just thought how horrible
it was oh god wolverine
that's i mean dude think about that in
bed like you're just like saying
you don't have to call him daddy there's
no way he wears yeah he looks like i
feel like he would have a mustache um
but i also feel like he'd be definitely
nearsighted yeah
i think i'll ascot
definitely he would wear an ascot in the
shower like i think he was very yeah yes
he'd be the guy that you briefly met at
the airport
sure for sure have been horrible 100
he's actually horrible
it looks like he looks i'm going to show
you photos it looks like
wow okay sidebar i'm gonna get in here
real quick i wanna ask you a question so
you said you looked at his feet or
looked at his shoes yeah you guys look
at shoes or hands so if you look at a
guy's feet right he's more like an eight
size eight seven are you like ah [ __ ]
i don't notice the size of a guy's feet
but i do notice their hands i know
that's like the first thing i like i
noticed the veins do you look at like
size of hands you look at like a hand
structure
that is such an interesting question
because hand structure what does that
mean like it's just
built differently
just like
if the cuticles [ __ ] up or like you
know me like that that type of stuff i
like clean hands but i do like like
stronger hands work okay that's total
sense we're gonna go big big hands so
you look at a dude and hit like tiny
hands yeah that's done really well
but i'm like i'm out yeah for that
reason i'm out uh
what's the size of
i have big hands look look look how big
my hands are huge okay like bigger than
most men what size should you wear
oh ten and a half ten and a half yeah
bruh what
toenail polish white
i'm wearing one
white or white here it is there it is
okay how many second graders do you
think you could fight off before you
become overwhelmed are they like vicious
ones no like a normal second grader okay
because in my head a second girl if i
hit a second guarded score in the head
and he knocks to the ground the other
ones are like [ __ ] that and walk away
but they're just vicious and they're
just okay so
they're amped up on um
i love this game yogurt
i think over
i think uh
i think about
10 i think i think about 10 and then you
get 10's a lot 10 is a lot here's a
problem i would have to kick them
because i'm breaking a hand yeah i could
make a street fighter push him on the
ground maybe street fighters yeah
because gta groups are small bro yeah
they're small they are small i feel like
yeah if they're like jacked up on
capri sun i feel like they would keep
going but what if they keep getting up
dude have you have you ever pushed
someone that's smaller than you like
give him a big push it's really easy to
push i can't say that i have that's true
i haven't read you well my sister is two
years older than me right so like she
always used to be my ass i remember the
moment sophie used to beat my ass all
the time
what's i'm older okay um so
uh yes so she always used to like be my
ass and there was i i remember when i
was in sixth grade she tried to push me
and i did i like took it and then i
pushed her hard as [ __ ] to the ground
and i was like we both had that moment
like oh this shit's over this dynamic
has changed you actually don't realize
how strong people are yeah honestly you
think oh yeah if i got like pinned down
like i could probably get up
you don't know someone's ability to be
like really strong we're also talking
second graders yeah yeah yeah yeah
you guys yeah you don't know their
strength man give them a break i'll push
so many second grades to the ground
aggressively we're gonna honestly i feel
like i've had a bad day like that would
feel really good it would you know what
i mean have you ever one of those rooms
you can break [ __ ] what's that called oh
yeah oh i did i went
to date yeah we're both for days yeah
can dates you're going through this one
wait it was actually
so much fun i'm sure oh my god you get a
drink before go at night
you do get fly away you get winded and
you realize you have zero cardio yeah
like what is it called cardiovascular
ability i don't know it works
cardiovascular abilities seriously after
like i think 10 minutes yeah winded
really yeah
whacking
if you're fighting with your girlfriend
like just say let's just hash it out
let's go to break room and you guys feel
so much better oh yeah hundred percent
if you do therapy and then that boy wow
boy
that's a great idea
wait that's a business i'm sorry what
you shoot the office and then you go to
the next one yeah like next door in the
therapy office you just break stuff or
do you want to break stuff after therapy
i think you might want to invert that i
think you break [ __ ] first you're like
and then it allows you to
open because if you do therapy first
you're not going to want to yeah it
depends on the package you select which
okay yeah you know we're starting
something we call it like breakdown no
we're calling it time no time
no no breakdown breakdown is
really
don't take it all right final question
yes if you were a chair
who would you like to sit on you i mean
it's gotta be sexual i don't give a [ __ ]
if like something see mine has always
been danny devito
mm-hmm uh please i changed my answer he
used to be uh he's a such a silly shaped
man mine's joshua he's so silly i want
dozie cat yeah i think you would have to
be like uh see you're thinking of like
the feeling of someone sitting i think
of her but
see it's funny i'm thinking of like the
the way they would smell
oh
think of that because in my because in
my head if i was a chair i would be this
right yeah so then the person seated i
would have like the hair in my face like
it would be like this i'm not thinking
of the actual feeling oh my god
yeah so i'm thinking of like their back
of their head like next to my this is
the best dancer we've gotten so far i
haven't even chosen anything i know but
your explanation is so good so there is
this lady and i i'm so sorry i cannot
remember her name
she is you guys ever seen knives out
yeah yes okay
yes she's so
she is so attractive but but beyond that
for some odd reason she looks like she
smells good yes yes she actually does
look like she's very clean good for you
anna yeah she's wearing videos if you
want to sit on michael
he's here
no hey
girlfriend that's definitely watching i
love you and you would be the first
choice yeah the second choice would be
knives i don't know last night oh my god
well thank you so much for coming on the
show today thank you so much for
everyone where they can find you stand
up coming like in so yeah the stiff
socks podcast every uh wednesday we have
a patreon every friday and then if you
guys want to see me on tour just go on
blou comedy.com blau comedy.com so uh
salt lake city and then a big la show um
in april so
i will be there
come on come on come on all right well
you can find us all there this is one of
my most favorite conversations we've had
i know okay flip flops be front row
waiting for the shirt to come off white
toenails
thank you guys so much for watching this
week and we will see you next time
[Music]
you